uh and mark is a measure of just how
long a shadow that bomb blast cast in
in beirut and and beyond that actually
when the the
blast of a fortnight ago and the port
happened people immediately thought back
to
hariri's assassination
uh absolutely uh colin in fact we were i
was just talking about
that now with a colleague there was a
thread a psychological and a political
thread which ran from that moment in
february 2005 the assassination
of former prime minister hariri the
thread ran
right the way to that explosion exactly
two
weeks ago initially people wondered if
it was another assassination the
beginning
uh maybe of more significant violence
for lebanon it turned out to be an
accident accident
but nevertheless the thread was still
there because the incompetence
of the current government links right
back
uh to the events of 2005. and i have to
say the the
verdict uh the judgment that came
through today will be a surprise for
many people in lebanon there was a hope
an expectation that these four
individuals all members of hezbollah the
militant group
uh within lebanon that hold that wield
such significant
power now and has done over the years
that they would all be found guilty in
the event
they weren't all found guilty only one
of them uh was found
guilty for his involvement in the
assassination of of mr hariri
his name is salam assa ayash he
was one as i say of four of the
defendants the other three
were found not guilty it was not clear
to the three judges beyond reasonable
doubt
that they were involved in his
assassination
and the prosecution had over the past
10 years more than 10 years that this
court has been sitting
put together many many bits of evidence
largely resting on mobile phone evidence
of the four defendants mobile phone
evidence which linked them not only
with the location of the assassination
but also
of mr hariri's whereabouts in the weeks
before he was assassinated it was
alleged by the prosecution
that these four individuals acting on
behalf of hezbollah
and um in turn on behalf of the syrian
government which back in that
at that time was contro effectively
controlling lebanon
uh that they had been trailing mr hariri
they had been working out the
appropriate time to carry out an
assassination
and it was the prosecution's view uh
that they those four men were
responsible
for his death not so said the tribunal
it was clear to them or it wasn't clear
to them beyond reasonable doubt
uh that three of these four men uh were
involved and so as a consequence
they have been acquitted now what will
this mean for lebanon well
it's hard to know really lebanon is in a
dire state right now
made all the worse by this the explosion
of two weeks ago politically it is
heavily heavily divided dangerously
uh divided um there was a hope and
expectation
that justice in the form of this
tribunal in the hague
would be an alternative for vengeance
now if justice
has not been seen to been taken by those
people who believe that hezbollah
and these four men were responsible for
mr hariri's assassination
then will vengeance take over uh that
clearly is
is the fear uh it forms part of
of the belief by some that lebanon is
heading towards um some very
very difficult days hard as that may be
to imagine um
sad son he too has served as a prime
minister in lebanon he wants to make a
a comeback he was in court in the hague
he did say to
in the last few minutes we accept the
verdict of the tribunal
and we want justice to be implemented he
said he wants just punishment for the
criminals
who killed his father he said those who
assassinated my father aimed
to change the face of lebanon and its
system and its civilized identity
and that there will be no compromise on
the matter
of justice so a surprise judgment i
think it's fair to say in the hague
today a judgment that has taken more
than
ten years to come about uh an awful lot
of um
of evidence put forward uh hundreds and
hundreds of uh of witnesses have come
forward many of them uh
not identified because of they they
feared uh for their life but um
the uh the conclusion three of those men
found not guilty the fourth found guilty
and interestingly the um the judges the
three judges also couldn't
um conclude beyond reasonable doubt that
either the syrian regime that bashar
al-assad or hezbollah senior leadership
were involved in the killing that is not
to say
some people will argue that doesn't mean
they weren't involved
it just means that um legally the
the court could not conclude beyond
reasonable doubt that they were involved